with a narrative Li complex seasons
under its belts American Horror Story
has left us with a number of doozies to
puzzle over with that in mind here's a
look at this long-running hits
anthologies biggest and answered
questions and there's more than a few
spoilers ahead Murder House American
horror stories first season set the
foundation for the series by introducing
us to the Montgomery house an infamous
mansion in Las Angeles with a
disturbingly high death count and a
history of violence that goes all the
way back to its first owners in 1922 dr.
Charles Montgomery played by Matt Ross
and his wife Nora played by Lily rabe
dr. Montgomery a surgeon to all of
Hollywood's finest in the 1920s built
the Victorian home for his wife he never
fails to remind her and it always fails
to impress her
I built you this house exactly the way
you wanted in how many servants do we
have till when they fell on hard times
Nora decided that Charles should start
offering abortions out of the basement
no no
but we do require payment after an
abortion went very wrong Charles is
exposed and the father of the baby
dismembered the Montgomery's newborn and
retaliation charge
crazed with grief at rolls sewed the
baby back together and we animated her
the child was bloodthirsty and Nora
ended up killing all three of them
there goes continue to haunt the house
along with anyone else who died there
well these terrible events enough to
shatter a psychic veil and create the
house where the eventual Antichrist will
be conceived and born what was there
something more this vital question to
the entire AHS Ark has never been
answered if people kept going missing
after booking a stay at a particular
hotel you think the place would be
positively crawling with law enforcement
but no not at the hotel Cortez
I need a rule like Murder House the
hotel wraps up an enormous body count
due to the evil energy of the place yet
people keep booking stays at the Cortez
and when they died terribly and
violently within its walls nobody seems
to come looking for them there does this
have something to do with an enchantment
on the site laid by the vampire contest
played by Lady gaga
she's been in the fashion industry for
decades yet nobody seems bothered that
she doesn't age did she cast a glamour
over herself as well as a hotel is this
somehow related to Gaga's role as the
original Supremes Kathak in Roanoke
something definitely seems to be up
after all the Roby show which is even
though queenie is there and yet nobody
goes looking for her that may be due to
some sort of black magic and consider
this when will Drake is killed at the
hotel his son Lachlan is also staying at
the hotel but we never see lockdown
again that the countess tournament to
one of the ravaging vampire children is
he still there and is he still alive
we just don't know we will probably
never know will we American Horror Story
asylum is packed to the brim with
bizarre occurrences we meet her supposed
it and Frank you left we get acquainted
with the serial killer bloody face we
witnessed the evil doing of a nasty
doctor who continues his file medical
experiments on patients but one of the
plot threads that still leaves us
scratching our heads involves kill
Walker played by Evan Peters and his
abduction by aliens after his supposed
abduction in return his wife also
disappears authorities arrest kit and
the suspicion of being a serial rapist
and murderer bloody face qutuz locked
away in Briarcliff asylum and
body believes his alien abduction story
yes story a little green men do here
they weren't human he suffers terribly
for crimes he didn't commit
we never get a definitive answer about
the aliens and American Horror Story but
wild Murphy discussed the puzzling
plotline with Entertainment Weekly
explaining that for me aliens were
always an obvious metaphor for God it
fits very easily into the world of a
Catholic sanitarium asylum it was also
about science versus faith so it made
sense to me still would like to know
what these malignant extraterrestrials
are up to then again aliens and
notorious for their wild ways American
Horror Story Roanoke features uber
driver Rhett snow played by actor Billy
snow and he seems to be the only working
driver in the area he gives cricketer
right almost killing flora by accident
on the process he's pretty good everyone
was alright he also gives Dylan a ride
back to mom Manor evidently totally fine
with the fact that the guy is wearing a
Pigman mask red shares the same last
name as a fashion each a wedge of Myrtle
snow and his first name is shared by
Rhett Butler in Gone with the Wind one
of clark gable's most famous roles could
read snow be a member of myrtles
extended family giving him an
old-fashioned name would be such a
Myrtle thing to do our other members of
snow family similarly driven by glamour
and glitz and were they eager to name
rest after a pop-culture figure from
days of yore if so is rep possibly a
warlock like his witch relative for the
feature in a future season we probably
wouldn't have seen him so many times
without a reason but what is the reason
in a horrifying reveal during American
Horror Story Murder House we discover
that the latex cloud of rubber man is in
fact the ghost of Tate Langdon and he's
the one who forced himself upon Vivian
impregnating her with Satan so who is
the second rubber man in apocalypse it
doesn't seem to be Michael because he's
walking the halls and interviewing
people in outpost three around the time
rubber man is doing his sexy business
then again a rubber man clearly gets
around gallant in the second rubber man
have sex and later on gallon two
startled when Michael claims it wasn't
him in the rubber suit in pathetic when
gallon sees the rubber man again he
stabs him in a fit of rage
but beneath the mask is not a man at all
no it's Cullen's grandmother bubbles
played by the legendary Joan Collins
there's a pretty eventful night sort old
was the second rubber man even real or
was he merely a hallucination
it's ironic that Evan Peters played the
original rubber man
the house only to be on the receiving
end of his assault and apocalypse time
really gets a flat circle huh American
Horror Story apocalypse spends a great
deal of time and attention on Emily and
Timothy the star-crossed lovers and the
end of times living in outpost three
when they're captured and taken in the
ground
they're both told that they were
selected for their excellent genes the
league the worthy those chosen to
survive their forbidden love only draws
them closer together by the end of
apocalypse and after the time recess we
learn emily has given birth to the next
Antichrist
why were they included in the apocalypse
bunker it's someone no Emily and Timothy
were destined to siren Antichrist in the
event of a time spell being cast to
destroy young Michael Langdon but I'll
pose three hoping for another devil
trial to rule the end of the world or
does this mean that the forces that are
trying to foster the Antichrist are well
aware of multiple timelines also Emily
and Timothy are both human and Satan
must be conceived with human and spirits
like Michael was so is one of them not
who they say they are could one of them
have been under an identity spell all
along so many questions American Horror
Story hotel ended with a number of
pressing questions that were never
resolved for example what's happened to
the countess's disfigured vampire baby
Bartholomew after she was killed in the
prophecy and became one of its ghosts
what was the significance are there
recurring to 25-hour oh and we have some
questions about that gang of real-life
serial killers each year on Halloween
they somehow managed to visit James
March the man who built the hotel Cortez
as you no doubt recall Richard Ramirez
Aileen Wuornos John Wayne Gacy Jeffrey
Dahmer and a mass OD a killer all attend
the dinner party and celebration of
Devil's Knights I don't get you man the
real fun starts after you get caught
don't you know that each year they drink
absinthe and murder together with glee
but none of these serial killers haven't
designed the hotel Cortez obviously so
how do they get there and were they all
chillaxing the rest of the year in the
world of American Horror Story ghosts
tend to say where they were killed but
not these prolific murderers what allows
these serial killers to go and join
James March at the Cortez for one night
a year does he have some witchy powers
that are never discussed or is there
something else behind their ability to
roam about freely and other ghosts do
this fingers crossed for a future season
that clears up these unanswered
questions from American horror story's
fifth season theories anyone
in American Horror Story coven evident
Peter plays Kyle Spencer the president
of a college fraternity when Madison and
Zooey go to a rating party Madison has
drugs an sexually assaulted by a bunch
of frat guys until Kyle intervenes
Madison is so furious about the attack
she uses her powers to flip over the
frat boys bus killing a great many of
them and also killing poor sweet Kyle
feeling guilty about Kyle's death
Madison and Zooey visit the morgue and
decide to resurrect him but there's a
problem
the boys are all left in pieces Madison
finds Kyle's head in them pics choice
body parts from the various dead frat
boys in order to create what will
respectively call a Franken Kyle the
spell doesn't seem to work at first but
when it does Kyle clearly isn't the same
kind hearted guy he was before he
eventually regains his strength and
ability to speak and by the end of the
season he becomes a miss Roby shows
Academy's Butler and protector a
Spalding at Ben we return to Roby show
an American Horror Story apocalypse but
there's no sign of Kyle at all evan
pizzas is all over apocalypse in fact he
plays for different roles throughout the
season mr. gallant James Patrick March
Tate Langdon and Jeff Pfister so it's
really rather odd that Franken Kyle
doesn't make a single appearance
throughout the season what happened to
him did he die again or could Ryan
Murphy be saving him for a future season
time will tell what was the witch
Mallory's real identity and why was she
so powerful we know that Queenie's
lineage goes all the way back to the
Salem witch trials misty dawn comes from
a long line of swamp witches supreme
Fiona and her daughter Cordelia are both
white witch royalty as are Madison
Montgomery and Zoe but we know virtually
nothing about Mallory or her past zombie
meets her as a personal assistant in
American Horror Story apocalypse she was
functioning under an identity cloaking
spell so it makes sense that she didn't
know who or what she was yet it seems
nobody else knew either apocalypse never
really addresses her identity or lineage
at all which is surprising people with
her level of immense power tend to rise
from well-known bloodlines this begs the
question is Mallory even a witch at all
we need Ryan Murphy to circle back
around to this one we learn an American
Horror Story coven that there can only
be one supreme at a time and when her
powers and health begin to weaken it
means another supreme is on the rise
Fiona had to die in order for her
daughter Cordelia to ascend just as
Cordelia's to die
malory to take her powers birth in
American Horror Story Roanoke many of
the terrible events are set in motion by
the Woodworks cottage who they say is
the original supreme but how can that be
if there's only one at a time
is she a ghost supreme does being the
first give her exceptional powers we
demand answers check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about American Horror
Story are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail said you
don't miss a single one
[Music]